clouds of steam covered the earth
near the city of goma after a long night
of fear
and uncertainty a volcano beneath mount
neregongo
expelled streams of lava from its crater
and these currents had flowed to the
city's outskirts
near the border with neighboring rwanda
hundreds of homes were buried or burnt
but the mountains seemed to settle in
the early morning light
we're still waiting as we can see it's
still smoking
we think the lava is heading towards
rwanda but i don't think it's going to
get that far
god willing it will stop right here
there was no warning given
of this eruption the night sky pulsing
red
as molten rock swept down the slopes of
mount neregongo
when a sea of lava built down below the
local government gave the order to
evacuate
but many had already made that decision
for themselves
some crossed the border into rwanda
others boarded boats
on the nearby lake the residents of
gomer
have begun to assess the damage a river
of rock
now squats on the city's edge the rubble
some two or three stories high in places
tangled remains of homes and businesses
are visible
in places and residents will need months
or years
to rebuild their lives they left a home
and they're coming back there is
nothing the house is not there all their
belongings their life investment is not
there
and people are crushed so that's that's
the situation right now that people are
coming back but they really
need uh support they need urgent help
because they've come back to to nothing
the volcano has cooled
and scientists say the city has been
fortunate
but that's little comfort to hundreds of
families who've lost
their homes see you and then
now i don't know where to go and we're
afraid because the fire is still visible
in the lava
life in gomer has never been easy but
the angry mountain
has made it worse john sparks sky news